alright so hello once again welcome to
Android design in action of for those of
you who who aren't watching live and
we're watching the YouTube per year old
or the YouTube recording we had some
interesting technical difficulties so
we're just going to start over and this
will hopefully be the kind of the better
version of the show episode my name is
Roman Nurik hey guys wait Adam Kosh and
today we're gonna be talking about the
we're gonna actually show a demo of the
i/o app we'll talk a little bit about
what that is in a second we'll also talk
about we'll do a deep dive and a narrow
dive as you pointed out before into
sharing as well as full screen you eyes
so we have a lot of content to cover
this may run a little longer than 30
minutes if it does then really sorry
about that but yeah too bad so let's
let's jump into the i/o app real quick
so the i/o app is is an app that our
team developed that helped Google i/o
2013 attendees I guess find their way
around the conference take a look at
what interesting sessions are playing as
well as interact with folks socially on
google+ and obviously is a responsibly
designed app there's there's a phone
tablet version supports 7-inch 10-inch
you know things kind of scale up
progressively so you know it's an
overall a quite nice happen we're guess
we're going to do a deep dive on some of
the details anything you want to add
before we jump in I think that we
mentioned on the previous run was that
it's an open source app so right now the
the source code that's out there is the
2012 version so last year's version but
later this year or hopefully in the
coming months we will be open sourcing
the 2013 version as well yes ok so let's
jump into the demo and let's hope this
it works this time so here's the app
running on 10 inch and 7 inch devices
forge oh I said I said it wrong the
first time ok so sephora inch and 10
inch devices you'll notice that there
are a lot of similarities in the visual
language i will talk about that in a
second but also just in terms of
navigate
on the phone you have you know tabs
representing your three top level
sections you have your kind of your
schedule which is personalized your
explore as well as your stream explore
contains you have things like a nap and
list of tracks and things like that and
then on a tablet we blow it up into a
kind of like a dashboard you I not
actually the dashboard pattern we're
looking for six pack of icons but it's
really kind of like a what's happening
now type of screen where you see your
current schedule upcoming sessions as
well as the stream of you know what are
people buzzing about what are people
talking about a Google+ about the
conference so it's it's kind of you know
interesting there are a lot of touches
that we we added to this app over
previous years and we'll do a deep dive
on that now so the first thing I wanted
to call out was just the the diagonal
patterns that we use throughout and this
is something that has been around in
Android for a while recently more
recently with like the google play store
as well as google play apps redesigns
we've kind of moved away from that but
we kind of held onto this pattern in our
app so this what I'm really talking
about here is this kind of diagonal line
pattern you can see here in the tabs it
may not come out well in the video feed
as well as over here in the scheduled
time heading and the same goes for on a
tablet the background actually of this
area is that diagonal line pattern so
it's just part of the visual language of
the app and we use it throughout as kind
of like a way to partly communicate or
partly introduce contrast rather than
using different colors but also just as
a kind of a visual stylistic choice so
the next thing I want to talk about was
in the schedule we actually have these
borderless buttons these secondary touch
targets and this is something that this
kind of cool if you have you know a
common other action for for a line item
so here rather than just choosing this
one this session that's in my schedule I
can just choose to see all items that
are in my schedule or for that time
we're all items in the all available
sessions in that
another one of my favorites is the
contextual action bar so let's say you
wanted to you know share something
immediately rather than jumping into the
session you could long press and you
actually get the contextual actions that
you can take on there you can also
switch to other sessions and you can't
actually select anything else since you
can't really do actions on them let's
see so moving on to the explore tab this
is actually something that's that's
fairly subtle and a lot of you that
you've used that may not have noticed
this so we have this map area at the top
and something that we do is on press we
actually desaturate the background so
you can see that the yellow these yellow
Road lines they actually become gray
another app that does this I believe is
google currents one of the reasons that
we decided to do it and this is just
kind of a good neat trick it doesn't
really add too much here but it's
something that that helps prevent kind
of color collisions between your your
touch highlight your kind of like semi
transplant as trainmen semi-transparent
blue touch highlight as well collisions
between that and the background contents
we also do this in other areas to think
for avatar icons which you can show
later and then obviously we're using
different weights of Roboto here in the
tracks list we use Roboto light and
actually four sessions that have passed
you can't really see this year because
it's after the conference but during the
conference past sessions were actually
type set in Roboto light to give them a
little less visual weight so that you
can hear I can naturally kind of focus
on things that are yet to come another
item in the visual language is we use
these kind of circle masks and we do
this throughout we use these in the
stream here so you'll notice that here
in the stream you know each each poster
each Google+ person that's posted
something is in a circle and this
actually gets is shown as well on a
phone if you jump in to say like the
track details you'll see that the top
left we use this kind of track icon
that's inside of a circle and the reason
for using circles I mean just as a
general selleck stylistic choice is a
mean
it's a it's almost like a cleaner visual
it's a little more light having a lot of
boxes and squares can can kind of you
know instantly make something feel a
little rigid make your appt feel a
little too rigid so just introducing
circles where appropriate it's not kind
of like a universal thing just throw
circles at stuff and see what happens it
may help kind of introduce a little bit
of softness or warm kind of make sense
for the Google+ stream as well because
the Google+ app also uses these circles
too for the effort us exactly another
one of my favorites is some tweaks we
did search so if we press the Search
button here you'll notice that you have
common keywords and this is something
that in the future we may want to look
tweaked to recent searches but here are
common keywords you can search for
search across the session corpus on and
we added this query refinement which is
actually really easy for developers you
simply just add a single flag and
pressing this button basically populates
the search field of that so you can
start with that search and then edit it
as you see fit and then the last thing I
wanted to mention on the home screen
personally was so the viewpager margins
so as we switch between different tabs
you'll notice that the margins there's
about a 16-bit margin there and they
actually use a somewhat beveling effect
very very subtle it's not like a very
heavy drop shadow but this bubbling
effect first of all I mean it introduces
more consistency when you look at the
tablet at all each of these I don't
wanna call them cards but each of these
pains of content is actually slightly
raised on its bevel it helps kind of
communicate these are the same thing if
you have a phone and a tablet just on a
on a phone it's it's just kind of
helping to further add a little bit of
dimensionality without going to you know
deep into skeuomorphism anything out of
that such as I think by default there's
no wreck there's no margin between them
so adding something there's something
just think about yeah yeah so um and
actually on a tab we talked about that
yeah I think that does all that I wanted
to mention about the home screen I think
I went to measure Hannah before you are
we covering the stream later or no feel
free to talk about anything I I mean
compared to the 2012 app we kind of
Roman actually redesigned the sort of
way that the stream looks here
and so avatars around and then there's
sort of this like area for content if
there's images available for those posts
or repost three shares there's sort of
this transparent overlay that shows for
certain types of post content so you can
see here there's this sort of like a
little over light image to indicate that
it that there's a image being shared
here you know in this case of the video
there's a little video overlay and we
actually use the center crop technique
there so right so whatever size whatever
with the the stream is we actually I
think we fixed the height and generally
this is not something you want to do on
on tablets if you have like really wide
stream items but using the center crop
techniques make sure that each of these
photos or media items media overlays are
fixed size but the content which can be
various aspect ratio stays within it I
think we talked about that last time
yeah and then two other minor points 1
as the images load there's a very subtle
sort of animation as they sort of snap
in and the other thing I wanted to
mention is on this fragment is um it's
very responsive you'll see it used in
many locations in the app and so you
know in this case it's sort of the same
with approximately the same width on
both tablet and phone but in other cases
it may take up a bigger portion screen
but it scales nicely depending on the
amount of width it's available to it
yeah all right let's jump into a track
detail so let's jump into the Android
track here on both screens I really love
this demo if demo setup oh it's finally
working yeah hopefully next time it will
be less quirky in the beginning with
okay so a couple things in the for the I
guess session or track detail as we call
this so the first is you'll notice that
there are very similar navigational
elements first you know on a tablet we
do have to pain you I and a phony about
a single pane you lie on a phone you
actually have tabs to let you switch
between the different I guess parts or
different items within a track on a
tablet or on a phone you neither on a
tablet you have a spinner at the top
that lets you kind of switch between
this so if i go from sessions to office
hours it'll just switch between that
and sandbox for example one of the nice
things that we wanted to mention was
that you do have contextual action bar
support here so you can even select one
item right so view one session and then
long press to select other items and
then take action on those actually in
this case there's no actions that could
take because this one is in my schedule
but if I if I only select things that
are not in my schedule I can instantly
add those Alta my schedule all at once
the so we also wanted to mention that
the track icons again like track icons
is one of the things that we added this
year we made sure that every track had
some sort of visual identifier to kind
of help you differentiate it from other
tracks so we use those track icons in a
lot of places on a tablet we use them in
the header here so if i switch to say
the Google+ track you want to set the
header actually changes the icon to
Google+ let's see what else we have so
another minor point is every UI element
that is interactive has touch feedback
so if I you know put my finger on here
if I just press down in here you'll
notice that there's that blue overlay
that the covers it too lets you that
indicates that something is happening
also the same we work if you use a
keyboard or something to focus that area
notre minor point is that the on a
tablet the spinner and the I guess this
this track spinner as well as the
session detail heading they have the
same height and that's kind of too it's
it's not really a it's there's no
interaction elysian for it it's just
kind of a visual way to align things I
don't I don't want to talk about liking
of which principle that is because I
probably don't know but definitely it's
it's one way to ensure that there's
visual balance across your new eyes to
align things were possible if there's no
kind of natural point of alignment does
it make sense to do that but in this
case we thought that it would make sense
to London
let's see sliding paint so one thing we
can't demo here is the portrait mode we
talked about this very briefly last week
but in in portrait mode if you were to
hold this tablet in portrait you would
actually have a sliding pane layout so
this left pane would would immediate
were would initially be invisible but if
you were to slide the detail section
over to the right you would kind of
slide out that left pane and this is one
way to kind of reconcile having the
smaller amount of width available on on
a 10 incher centage device in portrait
but making sure that they you know that
you still have access to the same
contents to kind of maintain the the
functional parity across portrait and
landscape so again the minor point
that's not something we can demo right
now and then we already talked about the
track icons in the action bar so
anything else we should cover for just
this section here those are some of my
favorites Oh actually what we'll cover
that in a bit yeah we can jump into
session detail yeah so on for the
session details this is one of my
favorite parts so one of the things that
we did was we remove the ad to schedule
button from the action bar so you used
to be kind of this this button over here
that would add whatever you're currently
looking at to the action bar Rachel garb
from the Android your user experience
team actually said you know it's it's
not really a good place for a key
fundamental action like that something
that should really be immediately
visible and really immediately kind of
gain the users attention because most of
the time they're going to be pressing
may be looking at sessions and they're
going to be wanting to add them to their
schedule another thing is that we
actually had it help overlay we had a
dialog pop up that said hey press this
plus button to add the session to your
schedule and that was just to indirect
so we wanted to make it a little more
direct and we basically move that item
from the action bar to an inline button
here this in schedule button so one cool
thing about this is that it sticks to
the top so since you know while you're
viewing a session session details you at
any point may want to actually decide
that hey this is interesting enough on
edges to my schedule so we decided to
make it stick to the top so that
you know as you make a decision it's
always there and the same goes for
tablet actually it's a little less
noticeable for tablet but it's the same
behavior another thing is that there's
the subtle animation this is actually
only for android 4.0 and higher as soon
as you add something to your schedule
there's a very subtle animation the the
plus becomes a checkbox or checkmark any
kind of animated sent to say hey it is
now banana it's almost like a subtle
reinforcement that the action is really
taking place it's not really in your
schedule very very subtle on earlier
versions of the platform we simply just
show in height there's some very basic
switching laundry to do that let's say
so another thing was just reinforcing
that kind of that visual language of
using circles throughout each of the
avatars here each of the speakers are
circles and if you notice when you press
on them they they kind of desaturate
again very very subtle touch if you know
if you generally have fairly you know
simple content you don't really need it
in this case four avatars it's probably
not really adding that much but if you
have photos if you have like Nia large
photos that may potentially clash with
the overlay you may want to do that you
see what else I guess you'll see the the
diagonal lines here in the header again
and then also the the section headers a
kind of a sort of recommended pattern
here you've got the old caps in the
small phone with the underline yeah we
could have used tabs right we could
definitely have used tabs i think in
previous versions of the app we did use
tabs but we've switched more to a single
scrolling experience where basically
rather than kind of doing a lot of
navigation back and forth between
content you kind of like you know slowly
scroll down and really peruse what's
there what's available so you go from
session details to speakers and then two
more stuff like submitting of course
each of these sections is sort of
dynamic in its height you know the
description could vary the number of
speakers get very and these sort of more
links at the bottom also a dynamic there
could be many of them or few of them
depend on which session it is yeah so
one thing I wanted to mention on on a
tablet I guess is the consistent
iconography and this is again
introducing some consistency
in the visuals that you use in your app
is just as important as following the
visual design guidelines of on Android
right to make sure that your app is
internally consistent one of the other
ways in which we do that outside of
using the diagonal line visual element
and the circles is this kind of
unification of presentation of sessions
that are in your schedule so first
you'll notice that there are these
little ribbons or I guess bookmarks that
have a little check mark in them and
these are sessions that are in my
schedule and the same is mirrored here
on the right in that add to schedule
button if I look at a session that's not
added you'll see that kind of the the
inverse the inverse state of that and
pressing that immediately shows the
little checkbook a check mark there so
these kind of subtle things help
reinforce or help create a unified
visual language across your your app so
let's see talk about that oh one other
thing was on session details you'll
notice that on tablets we use a larger
font as well as Roboto light for the
text here and that's partly because you
know it's is generally a little easier
first of all it's um it helps mitigate
kind of long line lengths long line
measure disasters but in this case it
really helps make the content feel more
balanced since there's a lot of space
here and if this were any smaller and if
this Roboto regular it may kind of feel
a little too dense so so using that
really helped on tablets the line
Heights a taller as well yeah the wine
Heights are ever so slightly taller we
use the Styles the resources frameworks
are just Donald's for this let's see so
let's quickly look at submit feedback on
the phone so submit feedback is you know
let's say you've seen a session and I
can do that in tablet as well but let's
say you've seen a session and now you
want to look at or now you want to
provide feedback so this is actually a
custom control that your own it's very
simple it's based on a seat bar there
are some crazy nine patches in there but
it's really just a fancy seekbar the
idea is that you know you have this
slider it's a kind of sliding scale for
ratings and we use the the standard
accent color it's like a we call it io
blue we use the standard accent color
rather than hollow blue in this
because we wanted to kind of introduce a
little bit more kind of color
consistency throughout and then at the
bottom you'll notice that we actually
use that same blue for for the the radio
buttons as well as the text field so the
little underline in the text field is
also the same color and the way we did
that we actually used Android holo
colors from Jerome vanderlinden I
believe an Android holo colors basically
lets you throw in your accent color and
oh just generate the assets for you so
your designers don't have to sit and
like you know draw out so thing that was
it for secession feedback let's jump
into the map but I think we're about at
about 20 minutes now so we should
probably hurry up but let's look at the
map here so here's the map and it's
using the new maps the Android Maps API
v2 I forgot the name of that but yeah
it's using the new Android Maps API
you'll notice that some of the
interesting things here first each of
these map markers is customized so it's
using that standard you know blue purple
red gradient inside their next is when
you open up let's say the sandbox area
right you'll notice that we use that
same styling for for showing icons this
is the same styling on a tablet where
you see kind of the title at the top
left I guess some sort of subtitle below
and then the icon on the top right and
you use actually a subtle gradient as
well to to kind of hint that this is you
know like I says it's part of the visual
language is there's no real meaning to
it I guess let's see what else for this
so we actually use bold condensed here
for the text so for very long it's a
really long when there's yeah so
developed for good for example for very
long titles both or guess Roboto
condensed helps compress that
horizontally so let's quickly look at
the pop-up so let's say I actually
decide to look at what's in this
what's in this room so if I touch here
on a tablet you see a separate pain
pop-up it's kind of a floating pain
whereas on a phone you actually get a
separate activity now if on a tablet i
decide to jump into one of these I can
touch in and it will you know load it
right here and again you see all that
consistent that same consistent uh you
know those same consistent buttons like
the ad to schedule button so on but you
also get this bread crumb at the top so
if I really quickly want to jump back to
roommate I can either press back or I
can just press this and I could
obviously dismiss this as well you
notice that showing that pop-up actually
automatically pans the the map so that
whatever was currently in the center
remains at the visible center okay so
that was the map other thing that was a
map there anything else we should cover
the live stream we can very quickly
cover it yeah I think we knew this was
going to go along so that's fine just
press that yeah so this is the live
stream activity so you can watch any of
the sessions that are being streamed
live on YouTube we just plugged in some
of our own values here so we've got a
dia inside a dia but we can't actually
show this on the phone but on the tablet
here on the left side you'll sort of see
one pain broken out and on the right
side there's a split between tabs for
the the sort of social stream from
google plus and then captions so some of
the live streams actually had live
captions as well on a phone device it'll
just be collapsed into these sort of
three tabs that fall below the video and
then I guess you can go full screen as
well here so this is the YouTube API for
android so sort of comes with all the
sort of standard bells and whistles that
you could sort of expect from the
YouTube player and will actually cover a
little bit more on the list of full
screen modes shortly after this appt
recap that's promote it right oh I can
show the full screen roll program I
let's see if it works yeah sure work
okay and then you can toggle the
controls will actually talk about this
in a moment with the toggling controls
you notice that almost everything the
status bar the navigation bar in the
action bar all fade away we're leaving
just the content and we'll talk about
that actually
the deep dive for a full screen you guys
all right so really quickly just to
recap you know there's a lot of cool
things in this app it will be open
sourced very soon well hopefully very
very soon where we're just waiting on a
couple of things to be sorted out before
we can do that and yeah it's you know
it's been a pleasure working on it there
are some things that we'd probably do
differently right yeah so actually at
i/o there was a an app clinic live and
one of the comments that reader gave us
is about the refresh button right yeah
so uh so we have this manual refresh
button at the top and when when you're
actually sinking content it'll show a
spinner in place but one of the comments
that Ian and rato gave us was that you
know why do you need refresh this should
automatically sync in the background
refresh should not be you know primary
action should be second there if
anything if at all and we do actually
have a Google Cloud messaging enabled
here so we do refresh you know on I
guess on push from the server so you
know we could probably just very simply
just remove the refresh button we're
moving into the overflow so definitely
you know if you have especially if you
have a sync adapter if you have google
cloud messaging turned on you don't
necessarily need refresh yeah you remove
that for next yeah i think the the one
other purpose the refresh button was to
refresh the the Google+ stream so we had
some limitations there in terms of you
know how we would fetch new content and
actually display it in line there but
hopefully in a future version we can
sort of get rid of that refresh button
just intelligently refresher as needed
yeah all right so that was a whopping
demo of the i/o app we probably have
like three seconds for the rest of our
content but a lot of good content left
let's see so let's jump back into the
slides there they are so that was the
i/o app again if you want to install it
now just to play around with it here's a
QR code but let's jump into sharing all
right so go through this very quickly
this shallow dive on sharing content so
I just want to talk about a few things
sharing something that's very
system-wide and so I think convention is
very important when it comes something
like sharing so hopefully whenever you
sort of users share action you always
use the the mail
give Android share icon it's actually
surprisingly something we see done
incorrectly many times so definitely do
that also avoid hard coding specific
apps or services so you know that there
may be a specific use case where it's
sort of useful to do that but for the
vast majority of cases you should really
be calling out to the system share
intent which I'll show you some example
of that in just a second rather than
sort of hard-coding to fire up a
specific app or a specific service that
receives sharing i think android users
have just become really really used to
being able to use whichever application
or service they want to use and so when
they don't get that they're just going
to be unhappy and it's going to be a
frustrating experience one other thing I
wanted to notice that you know sometimes
you want to do a really rich integration
with a certain you know network like
Twitter or Facebook that's okay too but
if you do decide to do that then make
sure that you have an equally prominent
at least kind of equally prominent
equally obvious visible yeah option to
share with other things on the platform
so if you want to do like a rich
integration that's fine but make sure to
also offer this as a viable until as a
visible alternative yeah and then lastly
you know share goes very very well as an
action bar action or is an action
provider which is something I'll talk
about in just a second as well or you
know alternatively if it's not sort of a
primary action for your particular
activity you can go into the overflow
it's also fun to put it in line you know
that's that's a valid option as well I
think just a lot of the time it does
suit the action bar very well though you
know if its primary goes straight there
in a visible action if not it can fall
into the overflow so let me quickly very
quickly talk through the sort of two
main ways that the shearing action goes
into the action bar so first of all
there's the share action provider so
it's kinda have to see here let's zoom
in a little bit this is sort of how it
looks it's going to be kind of hard to
see on the video of it just sort of see
this very thin outline with the share
icon a little a little arrow in the
bottom right corner and then right next
to that is sort of your most recently
used or most frequently you
application that you've used to share in
this particular application before so
tapping on that share icon actually
brings down this menu which shows three
additional share options this is ordered
by frequency of use and then if you tap
see all it'll sort of expand out to show
you the rest the really nice thing about
the show action provider is it's not
going to throw up this in a big dialogue
it sort of feels like you're still
within your application and it's it also
bubbles up any of the applications that
were using to share and orders by
frequency so sort of does all these
things for you while sort of still
letting you feel like you're inside the
application and then just sort of down
the bottom here you'll see for
developers to sort of implement this a
quick tip is to use share compared to
configure menu item it sort of does
elyse things for you in a backward
compatible memo so you and then the
other option is just to have it as a
regular share action so rather a action
provider it's just a standard action
item that goes in the action bar there
so here you should just use the standard
arm icon like i disgust and then call
out to the sub standard system share
intent which is action send and that
will fire up this system dialogue which
goes on top of your application here and
this is what the sort of more recent
version of it looks like on I think
jellybean plus the nice thing about this
is that it's been called by the system
so you get this sort of consistent feel
across all applications that are
creating this dialog it also is
optimized for larger screens so when
when it shows on a say a 10-inch tablet
it's going to go into multi well it's
already multi-column it's going to go
into probably three columns yeah and
also it's also worth noting that you can
add items to this so you can prepend
intense to show at the top here so by
default it will just show whatever can
respond to the send intent but you can
obviously add things at the top so like
I think I think it was pocket or there's
some app out there that actually
introduced a copy to clipboard we're
basically you can share the record to
the clipboard to get that URL and paste
it wherever else you want yeah and the
nice thing about this dialog is that you
know
very with OS version or maybe we'll
change it in the future OS version but
as long as you call us in 10 you'll get
the substandard system behavior there
and then just down the bottom again for
developers sort of implement this intent
use share compat intent builder and then
last quick point you know you can go
completely custom these are all
available programmatically to fetch you
know what applications can receive a
share intent generally it's not
recommended unless you want to do
something particularly different so
there's no slide for that here but just
something to keep in mind all right
let's keep let's keep on moving let's
keep it and roll into full screen new
eyes so this this is basically talking
about how you deal with system bars like
the status bar navigation bar where your
where your content is supposed to be
immersive like for example photos videos
or books or things about as you're
reading so very quickly just a couple of
definitions you have the status bar
which contains notifications as well as
time and date not date but time as well
as battery level Wi-Fi cell signal
things like that that's the status bar
used for terminology the navigation bar
is the bar at the bottom that contains
back home in recent on earlier versions
of the platform you don't actually have
a navigation bar because you have I
guess soft keys I never know if you
should call them soft keys or hard to
you have keys that are that are built
into the device for that so the
navigation bar is something that appears
on newer devices that don't have any
sort of keys on on the front and just in
terms of sizes for designers obviously
you care about the size of these things
they can vary from device to device
there's no single standard and you know
this kind of fits in with don't design
for one pixel resolution but in case you
are interested roughly and in general
the status bar is about 25 dips tall and
the navigation bar is rough about 48
dips I think on phones in landscape it's
actually a lot smaller like 40 tips but
don't rely on these numbers these are
numbers that will probably change in the
future into probably change on different
devices on earlier versions of the
platform there is this kind of combine
the bar that combine both the status bar
and the navigation
elements and this is also you know
generally 48 dips tall but this is a
more deprecated so if you see
screenshots especially with this they're
they're using the kind of the old the
older system UI style so make sure that
you you plan for both because if you're
supporting for example android 4.0
actually it was four point yeah four
point i was using this if you're
supporting android 4.0 and higher just
be aware that your buttons maybe your
notifications may actually be in the
bottom right at some point okay so there
are lots of different full screen modes
and this slide is littered with the
stuff but you basically have you know a
couple of modes you have normal mode
where everything is visible you have low
profile mode where the bars are visible
and actually you can selectively you can
you can mix and match what happens to
the status bar in the navigation bar but
the low profile mode still shows the
bars but it recedes them visually so
you'll notice that the status bar here
is dimmed you actually don't even see a
notification I kind you see just a
little a little dot indicating that
there's something there and then you're
back home and recent SAR also visually
recessed so they're also kind of a
little just little dots just hinting to
the user that hey there's something here
it's not completely you know
non-interactive but you know touch here
to find out and then a couple of points
generally when you use this kind of you
I something that works really well is
overlaying the action bar so here this
is actually the action bar you with a
semi transparency applied another
important point is when you touch on the
content you should always toggle right
so you should never permanently be in
low profile mode or the southern mode
which we'll talk about so touching
should actually be the action that
toggles things and actually in this low
profile mode you obviously also want to
hide other UI elements as well as the
action bar that's actually one thing I
should mention right after this so
there's another mode called hide
navigation and hide navigation hides the
navigation bar at the bottom and it's
usually tied it usually also hides the
the top bar the status bar so in this
case you have full control over the
pixels on the screen so basically your
app is drawing
everything to the screen and this works
really well for videos for video content
and one caveat here is that this isn't
permanent as soon as the user touches
the screen the system will automatically
show the navigation again because you
don't want to lock the user into a place
where they have no access to back home
in recent that's just really really bad
so there's one thing I wanted to mention
and oh right the one the last thing I
wanted to mention about these different
modes is you generally want to only
switch between two normal and low
profile or normal and hide navigation
and you don't want to have different UI
elements on the screen going on and off
at different times you actually want to
make sure that you either have the
status bar the navigation bar the action
bar and other UI controls all visible
like here or none of them visible so
basically this boils down to make sure
that the action bar visibility is tied
to the visibility of the other elements
on the screen the way I like to think
about these two is that load profile is
sort of for an immersive activity where
there may still be some user interaction
like maybe you're swiping through photos
maybe you're reading a book or something
like that whereas the hide navigation is
more useful for something where you're
not sort of interacting with it like
watching video you're just sitting back
and looking at the screen exactly
exactly okay so those are the different
modes just a quick a couple of examples
on apps that do this in our opinion
really well first is google play books
so you know by default you see this you
know your actual book is itself as well
as some controls at the bottom and the
action bar at the top but as soon as you
touch where she's not here as soon as
you touch the screen the action bar the
status bar
and the UI control at the bottom the the
scrubber they all fade out and then the
navigation bar goes into low profile
mode so what you end up seeing is just
nothing but but content nothing but the
body of the book itself and then there
are some actions here for back home and
recent obviously there should be visible
another nice thing that this does is
that the content doesn't jump so if I
touch to toggle the content doesn't kind
of realign you know software relay
itself out and this is possible on
jellybean so in jellybean we introduce
some new API is to make sure that this
is possible on earlier versions it's
much harder to do that if you're showing
and hiding certain things like the
navigation bar especially another app
that does this really well as pocket so
what they're also kind of a good reading
app but one thing that they do slightly
differently is they actually toggle they
also toggle on touch but they also hide
the system UI as you start scrolling so
as you start scrolling down it goes into
low profile mode it still shows the
status bar which is good because you
know if you have an email come in you
you want to be aware that something is
happening and also you know it shows low
profile mode from the navigation bar so
it's it's really really subtle but it's
very nice kind of focus so the thing is
you're really focused on the content
itself and lastly we have YouTube so
YouTube is kind of the canonical example
of a great video playing application and
obviously what YouTube does is they hide
everything possible when when you go
into this full screen mode so this is
again possible with the new jelly bean
api's yeah and oh one thing to note is
that in the new jelly bean api is one of
the caveats or Consequences is that the
navigation bar can actually overlay your
content so you notice here that the the
navigation bar is actually cutting off
the content so if you have something
really important at the bottom or I
guess in this case at the right of your
screen you have to make sure that you're
not necessarily using that flag you
probably just want to use a low profile
yeah the i/o app uses the YouTube player
API so it gets a lot of these things to
free it handles all the the full screen
modes for you and then one quick
developer tip I don't have a we're
really far over yeah is a is a if you go
to eclipse and I think IntelliJ or
Android shortly you can create a full
screen activity yeah which kind of
implements a pretty large chunk of this
behavior for you at least for photo
viewing or as a full screen viewing
activity here actually playing with it
yesterday I think there's a bug in it
I'll have to fix it but i usually get it
yeah there's definitely a great it's a
great starting point it'll get you most
of the way there for almost all platform
versions i think yeah all right so we're
going to fly through the design new so i
think we're about 40 minutes this is
obviously a very long episode let's just
quickly 5 through some design news first
I don't know how to pronounce the name I
love these guys I think it's Apollo or I
think it's a polo right Mikey can tell
us later yeah opelu opelu or Apollo Mike
on an Apollo team actually created this
road up this blog post called the hollow
grill ? Android design guidelines a
realistic approach and it's a really
kind of good perspective on how do you
treat the guidelines you treat them as
rules do you treat them as you know
visual guidelines or you know what how
can you deviate from them in which cases
should you it's not you know full-on in
depth it's not comprehensive but it's a
kind of a nice perspective on it
basically you know one of the one of the
anecdotes that he had was that you know
in one of their apps timer they
introduced a dark theme that used an
orange accent color and a bunch of users
were like oh this isn't hollow this
isn't Hollow because it wasn't it was
orange and not blue and that's
absolutely not true i mean could still
be in line with the guidelines if you
use your brand's accent colors so
definitely you know don't feel like the
guidelines are the end-all be-all of
design next taylor ling who's been on
here a million times has created it kind
of a UI design UI wireframing kit for
Google slides for I guess for Google
Docs and he also updated
his Photoshop version so if you're
interested in wireframing you know kind
of high fidelity prototyping I'm not
really prototyping high fidelity
wireframe stuff check this out for sure
totally did yeah so Taylor issued a I
guess very similar to the Android design
in action live lab that we ran at i/o
Taylor issued a redesigned challenge on
his blog if you interested in
participating I think he's giving away
google play gift cards as prizes so
definitely you know feel free to check
it out and I think this is not the what
knowledge anymore it's I'm glad you know
yeah so a gmail update went live in play
I think yesterday or maybe the day
before there's a few new sort of design
patterns in there worth checking out
first of all as the the navigation
drawer the official navigation drawer
pattern there is implemented in the new
gmail app so we didn't have the official
screenshots of the drawer out here but
you can see that it's got the the drawer
affordance in the top left and of course
thing that brings out the draw edge wipe
brings out the drawer and this replace
the the action bar spinner that was
there before mmm and then there's the
Refresh you I yeah so Gina the new gmail
app also has kind of a new take on a
swipe down to refresh type of you I has
been very popular in other apps it's not
done using kind of like an elastic band
type thing it's it's done using kind of
this this other type of visuals we don't
have it here but it's pretty interesting
if you want to check it out by all means
one thing will say is that this is not
an official guide line or anything this
is just one exploration of how refresh
can be done until you know something
gets published and we're not sure if
this will be published in the guidelines
but till something gets published I
wouldn't rush to kind of implement this
in your own apps unless you just you
know really want to for some reason but
yeah refresh our current best practices
for refresh are either automatic refresh
you know not even giving user the option
or the need to refresh or something in
the action overflow or action where it
is a very nice hollow take on this sort
of us wipe to to refresh yeah that's
cool yeah it's pretty cool Oracle
and I think this is authors none of
those last one okay so the last is this
new website called screen size es screen
sizes it's this really nice really quick
reference to common devices as well as
their screen sizes and densities so if
you're really quickly trying to you know
like do some you know back of the
napkin' calculation on you know dips or
something like that you can hop over
this website that has a list of common
devices also it's mobile-friendly so if
you pop it open on your on your android
device it'll look great and i think
that's it right yeah yeah what a doozy
so I think we promised a doozy and I
think we delivered a very long show
sorry for going way way over but it's
been a pleasure as always I'm Roman Eric
see you later guys Adam costs see
you next week right